welcome back everybody there's nothing
more i love in the summer than being
outside catching some sun but i have to
admit there's been some incredible tv on
the small screen which is why from time
to time i do head indoors from new shows
to returning hits tv's been amazing this
summer and this next show is no
exception
hey birthday boy gosh the tension in
your shoulders is off the charts what's
going on i took my clothes and some
things and i moved out this is probably
my favorite role i've ever seen you in
and i'm not just saying that and i'm
assuming it mostly had to do with my my
bare buttocks
i mean that might be a small part of it
can i give you a hand with that i'm good
i'm good i do dead lifts yo i do like
squats and stuff
baby i can tell i can tell there are
squats happening there
i can tell
thank you look how many guys in the club
are on grindr right now wait are you
offering me a pity three-way
good luck and um
thanks i guess
if neil patrick harris was signing up
for
grindr today what would be his name
listen you're a magician very sexy can i
say that i thought maybe
magic stick or the wand
the magic
magic wand nine
wow
nine
pacific and so truthful
it's not just the buttocks i'm
interested in anymore
you've had a husband and partner for 18
years did you think about what it would
mean for you to start over it made it
remarkably easy to
find the emotional
pathos and fragility
of breakup because i couldn't imagine
what life would be like
in that world it's one thing to not
imagine it it's another thing to have to
imagine it and to have to actually play
it brought to you by the new dq summer
blizzard menu featuring new reese's
pieces cookie dough dq happy tastes good